Elijah
what's up
what's up uh I got a question so go
when you were like 20 I'm 25 let me get
you to speak up a little bit because
you're a little bit low on the volume
when you were like 20 you're when you
think back when you were in your 20s
like and you had like a a lot of women
and like
like I have a problem with like dating
like I don't wanna
like I have certain women who I can just
bring to like my house
and I just like but like these were
these are like you know quick and fast
good good looking girls but it's like
quick fast type of girls and
I haven't been on a date in like a very
long time because like I just don't like
the whole because you don't need to pay
for your meal and just to get to know
you you know what I'm saying like I
can't but then I feel like I'm selfish
because I'm trying to find like a kind
of LTR type of situation so how old are
you I'm 25.
why do you want a long-term relationship
because I feel like I've
been through the whole like the whole
herd and I feel like there's no
there's no yeah I feel like I've seen
everything that I could see in the
single life so now I'm like
I feel like what do you um
what do you do in your life right now
like you're working or
in school yeah I'm working right now
it's not like a I work at a Google data
center so I mean it's a nice it's not
like entrepreneurship but I like it
it's all right I'm trying to get into
like the fitness scene but for right now
okay cool
does it pay well
it does it does it does all right I mean
it's just not what I want to do like
it's not what I want to do every day for
the rest of my life
so why aren't you focusing on that
why is this why is this why are you
using my genius brain power to deal with
a question around and
a girl why why aren't we using my genius
brain power on that because I like that
a lot better as a topic we can deal with
a girl thing in a minute yeah so I mean
I'm moving I'm moving to Texas in May so
I'm getting all that prepared you know
um
so I could be in the fitness things
there's more right now the state I live
in is a super small town type of state
so now I'm trying to move to like moving
to Dallas Texas and so there's a
conflict right there because you're
because your first question is LTR
right selfish LTR how do I get that sort
of thing but your plan is to leave town
anyway so what are you gonna do you're
gonna bring her with you you're going to
tell her to get lost
like this is a this is a cart before the
horse sort of thing right like your your
purpose your mission in life should be
your priority and if and if that and if
part of that strategy is moving to Texas
the last thing on your mind should be
how do I get a girlfriend
right see what I'm saying all right I
see what you're saying don't you have a
girlfriend right now why isn't it nicer
than when you're spinning plates
it's got advantages and disadvantages
um
it's it's gonna be more work than
spinning plates like I'll tell you that
I mean you know to deal with an LTR you
got to have better game than spinning
plates spinning place is easy especially
for a good looking guy like you because
you know you're just calling him up be
like yo come over there's no dinners no
dancing no flowers there's no
Valentine's Day yeah it's Elijah the Don
right yeah
okay
all right so you think no like you think
LTR is in your 20s are like a waste of
generally speaking the consensus you
know seems to be from those that have
unplugged that your 20s should be spent
building yourself up laying the
foundation for your life becoming like
building the man that you want to become
because men are made women are just born
like you know a woman's job is not to be
promiscuous and preserve her beauty a
man's job is to make something out of
himself and you're working a nice job
that pays you well but you don't really
like you're planning on moving anyway
right so maybe there's something else
for you on the horizon but you don't
want to get yourself into a position
where you're in a soul-sucking job for
the rest of your life so there's got to
be something out there something else
out there for you is it sounds to me
like you've already figured that out
but yeah don't think for a second that a
woman is gonna get you there
I just feel like I'm wasting time like
I'm not talking to that many girls but
like same time like it's like if I if I
have like a good week or I had a good
like good week in Fitness good weekend
work you know
that's why I'm wasting time trying to
call a girl tell her to come over grab
condoms like ask your question what does
your dad say when you talk to him about
this
he's my dad's a little plugged in Rich
so he's telling me that to get an LTR
get an LTR yeah it's not good it's not a
good I would of course I would say I
would say figure out women before you
get an LTR and don't rush into an LTR
let let her like okay here's a here's a
couple of pro tips for a guy like you
because you're obviously spoiled for
choice you don't have a problem you know
dealing with women they'll come over
wham bam see you later bye there's no
dinner there's no dancing there's no
flowers okay you don't have a problem
getting the attention to women you need
to figure out what dealing with women on
a long-term basis is going to look like
for you but you want a chick that's
going to choose you so so choose a woman
that's chosen you one she's gonna have
to be the one that comes at you and you
know is like Elijah dig your Vibe you
know I don't want to share you with
anybody I want to claim you where do we
stand you know have her open that
conversation and then you can set the
terms of the relationship you know as
you see fit you know you can decide how
it's going to look for you at that point
in time but that's really all that it
really should be for a guy like you I
mean spin plates let the cream rise to
the top
um you know if you want an LTR
find you know do it if that's what you
think is you know going to serve you the
advantages are you don't you don't waste
a ton of time dealing with just random
bimbos that fill up your days with drama
and texting and why aren't you talking
to me and all that kind of [__] you
don't like that's the advantage to an
LTR spinning plates takes up a lot of
time dealing with a woman in a long-term
basis in a relationship is going to take
up your game you're going to have to
have good game to deal with a woman on a
long-term basis because
their their interests and you know the
way that like
it's all fun and games for the first
little bit you're banging all the time
17 times a day you're you know you're
having a good time there's no arguments
this is nothing nothing everything's
great right
five six 12 months down the road there's
there's always some [__] that comes
up that you don't deal with you know
when you're spinning plates so like I
said there's advantages and
disadvantages but you're but your
primary objective
because look let's be honest if you want
to get hot when like Leah Leonardo
DiCaprio does it at 48 okay he's dating
a 19 year old the the internet blew up
today because Leonardo DiCaprio is
dating a 19 year old they're calling him
all kinds of names because he's got a
preference for younger gals right it's
not difficult
in any stage of your life to get
beautiful attractive women to enter your
frame be a compliment to your life you
know all that good stuff
where it makes a big difference for you
and for all of those outcomes is when
you've got yourself squared away
Leonardo DiCaprio can do that because
he's Leonardo the [__] DiCaprio
he's that guy
and he does it over and over and over
and that's his reputation people knows
that's who he is no trouble whatsoever
right yeah
don't you think there's like a risk to
spending plates though because like
there's a little bit of risk of course
there's risks you could get me too you
know she could make up some [__] you
can get a you get an STD you can knock
her up you know there's all kinds of
risks of course there's risk look I've
never said Chase Girls when have you
ever heard me say chase the girls chase
the girls I've never said that what do I
say Chase Excellence not women
women are fine and dandy they're
wonderful they can be a great compliment
to your life your boys aren't going to
take care of you when you get sick trust
me a chick will yeah if she loves you if
she's chosen you if she respects you a
chick will your boys won't do that right
but for you to have the option of having
that chick in your life and retaining
her
being the best that she can get needs to
be part of your objective not for her
not to keep her but for yourself so
you're spoiled for Choice she ever gets
out of line she loses her you know she
just becomes somebody that you need to
disassociate from and be like fine I'm
out
I have options I'm good
okay that's my take on it I mean look
you're gonna do what you're gonna do
you're gonna go chase you know the LTR
if if I could go back in a time machine
and I was you this is the conversation
that I would have with myself asking the
very same question Chase Excellence not
women women you know let them be a
compliment to your life invite them in
your life if you want if that's what you
really want but
you know plan plan your life out better
so that it's questions like
how do I get the most out of my life how
do I get to where I want to be
right yeah
all right what is the best version of
myself look like
yeah I got a few more all right I got a
few yeah we'll be there
all right thank you let me know how you
make out man yeah I'll call you back I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out